of course the big win sent a wave of
excitement throughout the entire Valley
thousands of us were at watch parties
and when that final horn blared and
let's go out to eight news now reporter
Candace Charles for a reaction this
morning good morning Candace
good morning good morning folks yes fans
we're super excited when we finally got
that win as to be expected and now today
we're going to try to get some of that
championship gear here at the Arsenal at
Sea National Arena now inside T-Mobile
last night fans tossed tons of lingos on
the ice won the reigning Champs made the
final move and we won we saw some of the
little ones there grab them some of
those flamingos what a great moment to
see now the excitement was mentioned
rippled throughout the valley as
thousands watch and watch parties all
over the valley including Summerland
outside the Shiva Plaza many saying how
much of the win it is not only for the
team and its fans but this community
I see all colors flavors sizes
everything and and then we're talking to
you like you know them they're like oh
you want to sit over here oh you want a
beer or you want a soda anything it's
like we know it we were family we were
family
yes the community continues to come
together and rally around our Champs you
can expect a line here they're already
expecting you guys to be down here when
it opens up at 10 A.M to get your
championship gear of course you can get
it online as well we got you covered
with details on our website newsnow.com
for now live outside City National Arena
in Summerlin I'm Candace Charles 8 News
Now